Jay-Z is a 5enter. They believe the
black man [music] is God and the white
man is the devil. Jay-Z, one of his
nicknames is Hova. He says, "I am
Jehovah, God MC."
>> Jesus can't save you. [music]
>> There's someone very famous who's a high
elder in the church of Satan. Marilyn
Manson. He's been at Kanye West at
churches.
>> So Kanye and Justin Bieber and Marilyn
Manson were all there for long, the
producer from Diddy. They were having
seances. They were praying over the
music. Willow. She performed it at her
Aerys tour and [music] they have a
full-on like witchcraft kind of
performance and then this guy shot a Tik
Tok video and he shouted, "Summon the
demons."
>> So, I've learned there's two things that
are very difficult to talk about. Don't
talk about my plate. Don't talk about my
[laughter] music.
Why these two subjects I honestly
believe that people like have a
difficult time with is like think of all
the emotional experiences that you've
had with music. you all the emotional
experiences you've had with food and
what's wrapped around that. So, I'm I'm
excited to get into this. Thank you for
coming on, Dr. Walsh.
>> It's good to be back. Um, and this is a
topic that's very near and dear to me.
Um, I' I've tried my hand at being a
musician when I was younger and
[laughter]
was in a reggae band once and a hip-hop
band and um, you know, even today, as I
was mentioning to you guys um, before
uh, I do have a half brother who's very
big in the music industry. He's um
>> uh Grammy award winner um and has been
very successful. So I you know music is
something that's been very close. Um
I've met most of the big reggae stars
people from like Steel Pulse. Some of
the people who know reggae will know
Black Steel Pulse, Blackhuru,
>> Oswad, um Bob Marley,
>> Tony Rebel, my I have a cousin who's Bob
Marley's first niece.
>> So I used to spend time at Bob Marley's
house in Miami. I got to know his mother
well and went to school with his
brother. Um, and so I know that family
well. I know, you know, I know some of
Bob Marley's sons. Um, so, you know,
I've have been connected with that and
it has spoken to me as the power of
music. I was raised at Venice and, uh,
honestly, reggae music and hip-hop
really moved me to a place where I would
almost have left the church just based
on the influence of the music sources.
>> Wow.
>> When you listen to, for example, that
old school reggae, I don't know what
reggae talks about now. I know it's a
lot more, as they say in Jamaica, more
slackness now than it used to be. But um
when you talk about like reggae and
rastapharianism, it was like an
evangelistic tool,
>> almost like a religion.
>> Interesting.
>> It is a religion. Rastafarianism.
>> But the music reggae became like their
gospel music.
>> Interesting.
>> So how so you know people I say this in
sermons and people always like what why
would you say that? But it's the truth.
I've met blondhaired, blue-eyed
Rostafarians.
>> Wow.
serious weed smoking back to Africa
Rostapharians.
>> So like they were Caucasian but because
they got into the music they got into
the religion
>> the music and the weed
>> converted in.
>> And the same Mexican uh roastians in
California you know of Mexican descent.
And so music has the kind of power where
it can make you believe what makes no
sense for you to believe.
>> Right. Rastapharianism is a is a
statement against you know colonialism.
It's against being in the west. It's a
call to return home to Africa. It's a
statement that the former emperor of
Ethiopia Haley Salassie was God himself.
As one reggae song says Haley Salassie
was Christ in his kingly character like
Jesus come back as God. Bob Marley's
wife, Rita Marley, says that when Haley
Salassie landed on the plane in Kingston
back in the 1970s or 60s, whenever it
was, and he held up his hands, she could
still see the nail prints in his hands.
>> Oh, wow.
>> As if he was Christ. Now, he was an
Ethiopian Orthodox, you know, Christian.
He denied everything and they said,
"Well, it wasn't him. That was the
interpreter saying that." So, you you
this thing, I mean, it leads you down a
rabbit hole. It is powerful. And as
we're going to talk about today, music
has the ability to make you not want to
believe what you've always believed. Let
me say this from the outset. In heaven,
probably one of the great tools Satan
Lucifer used
>> was music. Yep.
>> I cannot believe he deceived a third of
the angels and he didn't use his musical
gifts and talents,
>> which he had. I think it's either Isaiah
14, Ezekiel 28, one of those
>> 28 says he built with pipes and tabets.
The Bible clearly says that he, you
know, the the, you know, there's the
songs of the the angels of the morning.
Uh, he clearly was a musical being. He
understands what music can do because
God created music as the vehicle through
which God would be worshiped.
>> Yeah.
>> So if you if you start with music,
understanding music that way, it was
created to worship God. What then does
God's great enemy, Satan, and he is not
on the same tier as God, but he's God's
enemy.
>> What then does he do with music? And
we're going to talk about that today.
We're going to look at science. We're
going to look at a lot of things to
really try and make the case that in
fact, your salvation is intricately tied
to what you do and don't listen to.
>> This is going to be cool.
>> So,
>> that's a statement right there.
>> It is. It is. So let
>> there's a reason why Madonna said that
music is trans transcends all languages.
It's like the universal language, right?
I think YouTube even YouTube you two
even said that there's many musicians
that have said look this bypasses your
frontal lobe and everything and goes
like directly into your your inner
being. And so there's a big reason why
we play music for the altar calls and
things like that. You know, it's like
opening the heart to receive that
message. And what's the devil doing?
>> Let's even step back from that. There's
a reason when you go to the grocery
store
>> or the Ross or TJ Max,
>> they play the music they play because
they know what demographic is going to
buy the most clothes. So you say, "Well,
if they want music, then why are they
playing the hits from the 70s and 80s?"
Well, they go they know the people with
the money in the store today are people
who like music from the 70s and 80s. And
once they get you singing the Commodores
and and and and you know old uh Beatles
music or or whatever it is, they know
that they take you to a happy place
where you're you're going to be much
more loose with your spending.
>> There's a it's no nothing is done by
accident when it comes to marketing and
making money. The music in commercials.
>> Yeah. Uh, and I always even say this,
you guys know more about movies here at
this ministry than I do, but even the
music they the music they used to score
the movies the it without it the music
the movies a lot of times don't even
make sense. That's right.
>> Someone challenged me once and said
watch a scary movie scene
>> and remove the music. Now I don't I
cannot watch scary movies so I never
watch them so I didn't exactly I knew
what he was talking about but I don't
watch those movies but he's right. If
you take a clip of one and I think they
have them on YouTube and you pull out
the music,
>> it's not scary anymore,
>> right?
>> The [clears throat] same exact acting,
the blood, the gore, the knife,
>> it actually looks silly.
>> It looks stupid.
>> So music is that powerful. So the
question for everyone today is what is
the score? What is the background music
of your life?
>> What are you playing? And what is it
saying about your relationship with
Jesus Christ?
>> Interesting. And if Jesus was to take
your phone and pull up your Spotify,
>> would what he finds on your Spotify
>> be pleasing or displeasing to him?
>> That's
>> that's the question. So let's look at
music a little bit. Um just to look at
it. We we already it was already
mentioned that music bypasses the
frontal lobe. The frontal lobe is the
front third of the brain. What's most
important is probably the prefrontal
cortex. So if you've ever heard my
sermons, I talk a lot about the seal of
God. It says that it can only go in your
forehead. That is relevant because that
just behind your forehead bone, your
frontal bone here is the part of the
brain that is the highest part of your
brain, the most sophisticated. This is
where judgment, reason, decision-m,
social interaction,
sexual uh behavior, all of that sits
behind here. It is also I when I speak
about it, it is also if you lay the body
out like the sanctuary, it would be the
equivalent of the most holy place in the
sanctuary because this is where sin is
dealt with. This is why Isaiah 1:18
says, "Come, let us reason together,
says the Lord. Though your sins be as
scarlet, they shall be white as snow
because that's where everything is taken
care of." So the lesson is that
ultimately what Satan is really after is
the destruction of your frontal lobe.
>> Yeah. You do drugs, you drink, where's
that effect?
>> It destroys the frontal lobe. Um, and
this is why the mark of the beast can be
given in the forehead or in the right
hand.
>> You don't need a frontal lobe
>> to follow Satan.
>> Yeah.
>> Right. But you have to have one to
follow God.
>> Yeah. And the hand represents actions in
the in the Bible. And so you can choose
like I don't want to worship this God,
but I'm going to get thrown into prison,
not eat, so I'll do it. Actions.
>> Exactly. You do it passively almost.
>> And you cannot do that with God. God
will not accept a passive I'll do it I
fear you I'm scared it's like no God's
like I want you to love me which is
right here
>> and hence so [clears throat] so music is
important on both sides of this um so
the frontal lobe is where salvation
happens literally it's where we make the
decision it's what makes us different
from the animals 33% of the human brain
is frontal lobe the next smartest
animals are porpuses and chimpanzees
their brains are only 13% frontal lobe
>> oh wow
>> a dog is 7% frontal lobe
>> this is also what makes you able to
worship.
>> Yeah.
>> To worship God. So, a lot of people
think worshiping God is an emotional
experience. That's further down. True
worship,
>> and I have a sermon recently called
God's love language. God's love language
is obedience.
>> That can only happen when you commit
your frontal lobe to him. So, what is
Satan trying to do? This is what we're
going to talk about. He is trying to
influence your frontal lobe away from
worshiping and obeying God.
>> Yeah. Or bypass it.
>> Bypass it all together so you don't use
it. that that's what he's after. He
wants to to desecrate the most holy
place in your sanctuary, in your temple
body.
>> That's what he wants to do. And there's
nothing more effective to do that than
music.
>> You brought up, you know, movies and
scenes and things like this that that
are, you know, in conjunction with music
like like you see these two things
working together. And you know, the the
way that the brain works, if you just
look at simple like an fMRI study of
someone's brain when they're watching
something, a lot of times because of the
amount of information that's being
thrown at you, and we're talking about
fast-paced, you know, entertainment
style television, you will actually
bypass the frontal lobe and open up your
lyic system, shutting down the blood
flow to the frontal lobe. And so your
mind, it's like opening the gates,
recording everything, but you're
bypassing the very thing that's that's
making choices about what you're seeing.
And you then are no longer critiquing
it.
>> Yep.
>> You're just letting in problem. And so
now you begin to believe things. So what
I we're jumping ahead, but one of the
things I say to young people all the
time is you think it's your idea that
you don't like church.
>> Y
>> you think it's your idea that you don't
want to go to church or that you don't
want to go to family worship.
>> You've been programmed. Yeah.
>> To think that by what you watch and what
you listen to.
>> So here's the, you know, you can see
that's it. But here's here's how to the
brain on music. And some of the things I
want to highlight is that when you
listen to music, it does release
dopamine.
>> So, it actually makes you feel better.
We're talking about reggae music. You
play Bob Marley, it just makes you feel
better. I mean, it just does. There's
something about the baseline and the
beat and the voice. It really makes you
feel better. So, music does all of these
different things. I won't get too much
into it. I don't want to get too
scientific, but it does release
dopamine, which means you like to go
back to it. You learn as you look at
this one. It boosts learn. It stimulates
both sides of the brain, the left and
right hemisphere of the brain
simultaneously. So it boosts learning
and information intake augmenting
clinical skills. And this that that
third bullet, the second bullet,
learning may be increased fivefold.
>> Fivefold. So you learn five times better
when you listen to music than if you
weren't. And it can aid the production
of serotonin affecting feelings of
satisfaction.
>> Wow. So, you know, like you learn simple
things when you're a child through the
use of music ABCD EFG. You know, you
sing it to a song. Yeah. You like
totally keep it in your mind and stuff
and and you know, Moses taught the
children of Israel
>> the the the commandments of God using
music. And so, we know that that's an
excellent way to lodge something into
your brain. So yes, it does matter what
are you associating as you're learning.
>> Absolutely. So the reason this is
important then is when we even go to
church and we listen to music, does it
matter
>> if it makes you learn so much better?
>> Does it matter what music you listen to,
even when you're serving God? We'll come
back to that. But I want to I want to
jump to the spiritual side. 1st Samuel
16:23 says this, "And it came to pass
when the evil spirit from God was upon
Saul that David took a harp and played
with his hand. So Saul was refreshed and
was well, and the evil spirit departed
from him." Here's the question.
If you can play a demon out of someone
with music,
>> can you play a demon into someone with
>> Yeah. Didn't you um a while ago you and
I both use this guy for disguise clips
for live show. His name was Rod Lang
Long, one of those.
>> He was a producer for Diddy's music.
>> Oh, wow.
>> And he became a Christian and a pastor
and he talked about this exact thing.
>> And he was like, "Yeah, I was in the
recording studios, not with Diddy, but
with other artists." And he's like,
"There's full on seances that they were
doing."
>> Oh, yeah. I've heard that. I I tell a
story all the time. There's a guy G.
Craig Lewis used to do the um the videos
called The Truth Behind Hip Hop. Yep.
>> And he tells the story of the guy who
was in the group Color Me Bad.
>> So if you you may remember they had
their hit song was I Want to Sex You Up.
>> And um
>> Yeah, I've heard of that.
>> Big song. It was number one in the all
over the world.
>> And um
>> one of the guys, so was I think it was
two white guys and a black guy. And I
think the black guy ultimately went back
to church and like said, "No, I can't do
this anymore." left millions of dollars
on the table, became a pastor, and so G.
Craig interviewed him, and the guy told
a story that when they were making that
song, I Want to Sex You Up,
>> um, they actually brought witches into
the studio
>> to put a curse or a hex on the song.
>> Oh, wow.
>> And he was like, whatever. Like, you
know, I just want I'm here to sing and
make money, whatever. I'm sure this is
just foolishness they're doing. He
didn't take it very seriously. He says
that the curse was that when 13, 14 year
old girls hear the song, they would want
to give up their virginity.
>> Oh wow.
>> And so again, didn't think much of it.
The song was number one in Canada,
England, US, Australia, all over the
world.
>> They get the fan mail starts coming in.
>> 13, 14 year old girls. Thank you for
making this song. It gave me the courage
to lose my virginity.
>> Wow.
Uh, I don't have the I don't have the
slides here, but I have a slide of when
Jay-Z was making the his, uh, hit song
99 Problems. Now, um, you know, I Jay-Z
kind of comes I I, you know, I was never
a Jay-Z listener. So, I I went and on
YouTube and looked up that video and if
you watch the video, Rick Rubin, who
helped start Def Jam Records, um,
clearly a talented dude, but I think
also does some very dark occult stuff.
Um,
they have as Jay as they're going in the
studio to record 99 problems, the camera
pans down and actually like
screenshotted and used in some of my
talks and there's a a book. It says uh
book of m book of magic, white and black
or something like that. Interesting.
>> So, as they're going into the studio,
they make sure you know they're going in
there and and not magic is going to be
done like, "Wow, magic, you made great
music." Like, no, magic is being done.
Yeah. like demons are being called in.
And so these mute these songs really
begin to sell. And so again, let me go
back. If you can if the Bible makes it
clear in 1st Samuel 16, if you if David
could play his harp and the evil spirit
leaves Saul,
>> y
>> can you play music that would send a
demon in?
>> Yeah. No words, just the music.
>> Just the music.
>> That's what Rott Long was also talking
about. He said it's not about the words,
it's about the music. And he
specifically mentioned hip-hop
>> that it's invites spirits.
>> Music is an expression of the soul,
right? I mean, I understand this from
being a being a filmmaker and and you
know, you don't play certain types of
music if you're wanting someone to feel
like on edge or like nervous or
whatever, right? You're not playing like
super calming music. You you're you're
matching the feeling that you're wanting
to relay. And so it's like, you know,
it's it's it's kind of like if you're
trying to relay this like worship
situation, but it's like this cool like
vibe, you know, thing going on like it
like like it doesn't match, you know,
and and the words are really an
experience that is wrapped up also with
the music sounds that are giving you
that experience.
>> Yep.
>> I agree. And the verse I always use for
people is this one. Um, and I think if
you're a parent especially, remember
this verse. Ecclesiastes 7 verse 5 says,
"It is better to hear the rebuke of the
wise than for a man to hear the song of
fools."
>> Interesting.
>> Um, and so how does the Bible define a
fool? The Bible says, "The fool says in
his heart,
>> there is no God."
>> It is the denying of God that makes you
a fool. So when we listen to music, we
have to be careful that we're not
listening to the songs of fools.
>> Amen. people who deny God, don't respect
God, or they claim to know God, like
they, you know, they go up and collect
their Grammy and say, you know, I want
to start by thanking God, right? But
they've just been they winning a Grammy
for an album that that promoted all
kinds of vice and immorality, right? But
I want to thank God. Which God are they
thanking?
>> Right?
>> Ask yourself exactly. Who are they
thanking? Sometimes they're literally
thanking Satan.
>> It's true.
>> Um, so understand that this this this is
really important. We look at look at
this here. A 2006 study of almost 1500
teenagers found that teenagers who
heavily listen to music featuring sexual
subject matter are more likely to start
having sex earlier than those who do not
by a margin of almost 2 to one. Wow.
>> The study's authors found that the
pervasive message in such music that of
study carefree men and subservient sex
object women is reinforced even if it
isn't closely paid to paid attention to.
opining. We think that it the music
really lowers kids inhibitions and makes
them less thoughtful in terms of their
decisions. Let me make sure to to to
>> highlight that this is not a
Christianbased
study. I believe this one is out of the
journal pediatrics,
>> right?
>> You know, it's a secular, you know,
non-Christian thing. And this is what
they're saying. They're not trying to to
bend your mind to a moral decision here.
It's like they're just [clears throat]
saying matter of fact, this is what's
happening.
>> We we recently released a show on
Sabrina Carpenter. She's like basically
the be the new big artist that's hanging
out with Taylor Swift and all those kind
of people. And her music videos
specifically are extremely sexual but
also extremely violent. So you got sex
and violence connected connected. And I
found a similar study that was a
completely secular study where they were
talking about when young girls are going
to watch these kind of music videos,
they're being educated,
trained even if they don't understand
that later on they will eventually start
sexualizing or acting out what they've
been seeing and listening.
>> Well, it goes back to what we said
earlier. It bypasses the frontal lobe.
>> So you w you expose yourself. So imagine
now. So this is just the music. So when
you add the video to your point and this
may be the same study, a later study of
such im imagery and videos, this one
focusing on teen women and younger girls
confirm the likelihood that frequent
exposure may not only influence how
girls see themselves with greater effect
the younger the girl is, but also could
actually uh affect their ability to have
healthy relationships,
>> right? And so this woman talks about
essentially when women perceive this
scripting that's in the media, this can
affect, influence or inform how they
think men and women should behave toward
one another.
>> So you say again, well these kids, you
know, you know, they're not getting into
this stuff, you know, because of, you
know, the music. But a lot of times
what's actually happening is the enemy
is working on multiple fronts to move
children, young people into behaviors
that will destroy the rest of their
lives. Music again is like the score.
It's like the background uh influence
all the time that's consistent because
everywhere you go, you'll hear Taylor
Swift, you'll hear I don't even know the
Sabrina Carpenter, you'll hear the
rappers, you'll hear whoever. And what
we don't understand is as Roger Renault
talks about this in the book of Trip to
the Supernatural. He says and he was
just and back then of course all
celebrity was local.
>> You know they were Hollywood stars but
it was your city. You had the who was
the best band in that city. You went to
that jazz club or that nightclub
whatever it is and you heard that band
live. And he said that all of the best
entertainers
or the biggest entertainers weren't the
most talented. Mhm.
>> He said once he started to worship the
demons, he talks about the fact that
they would be seen worshiping the demons
as well. They would be there at at these
events. The best doctors, the best
lawyers, the best everybody would be
there because it wasn't about it isn't
about talent. So the best singer isn't
Taylor Swift or Beyonce.
>> They're just the ones that somehow Satan
has given them permission will
>> to go all the way up that high.
>> Yeah. And and when you mentioned Roger
Mno, he was a former Satanist who was in
seances in these kind of satanic circles
and was about to be what do you call it?
Um he was like finally inducted and he
just before he left and he became a
Christian. So
>> he worshiped demons. I mean that's
literally what he was into in mansions.
I'm glad you say that because everybody
may not have read the book but he
worshiped demons in a mansion. beautiful
places, he says with elite people is who
he worshiped with in Montreal, Canada
after he came out of the merchant
marines after World War II. So,
>> uh it I I I say all of that to say,
listen, it's no one is a super mega
star.
>> Yeah.
>> And doesn't pay some homage to the one
who controls this industry. You know,
you got to think of like um Satan has
had 4,000 years of experience on
humanity and seeing them fall and
knowing exactly what what what to offer
them and what not to offer them, right?
And he knows that he's going to come up
to this time that he's going to confront
Jesus, right?
>> He's got three choices.
>> You're going to pick three things that
you have 4,000 years of studying
humanity. You got three. One of them he
throws at them is like, "I'll give you
all these things. I'll give you it all
if you just worship me.
>> And Jesus was offered that and he said
no.
>> Yeah. The very basis of all that stuff,
I guarantee you if you really sat down
with probably most of the celebrities
and they were dead honest with you, I
guarantee you they probably all have
been confronted in some way, shape, or
form. And we're talking the top one.
You've seen you've seen enough evidence
of, you know, uh, Bob Dillons or
whatever that talk about it, you know,
for actually time you've heard it. Yeah.
How many of them have done that behind
closed doors that you don't?
>> And so we have a couple videos on our
channel actually of actors and
musicians, artists that say, "Yeah, like
I sold my soul to the devil." They say
it,
>> you know, in one shape or form or the
other. And so it's interesting, like you
said, why would you see that pattern
over and over and over if this is just
one big joke and they're all just like
in a in the on a joke and we just don't
know it? And I honestly think that's why
you see these top performers almost like
as if they're worshiping Satan or
they're worshiping self or they're you
know requiring the worship themselves. I
mean, by default, you're worshiping
Satan when you're asking people to
>> I recently, and this video might come
out way after this has has happened, but
the VMAs were happening, the video music
awards, and Lady Gaga came out, and it
was like like all her dancers were in
this cage, and they look like a bunch of
de demons who were trying to like get
out of the cage. And she looked fully
satanic. I mean, she frequently looks
fully satanic, but I believe that there
is a purpose for this. Katy Perry when
she some kind of award show and she was
like a witch on the broomstick getting
burned like all of these different
things
>> Beyonce dressed up as like a sun god why
do we not parade around like that you
know because it's not it's not in our
lif style like this is not part of our
life but out of the heart the mouth
speaks right
>> amen
>> so
>> well the other thing is if in order for
them to keep the stat their stature they
have to pay homage publicly to the one
who gave them their position. Yeah, I
believe so.
>> And hence you see these things. I
remember when Beyonce did the Super Bowl
>> back in the 2000s, I think it was. Um,
you know, and she did all this satanic
hand imagery and all this. It was all
over the internet. And anybody can go
back and look at it for themselves if
they want to.
>> And what what a lot of commentators at
the time were saying is you can't get
this high without
>> Yeah.
>> speaking or referring people back to the
source of your power. Satan wants
ultimately what does he want? You go
back to Isaiah 14, Ezekiel 28. He wants
to be worshiped.
>> Yeah. Those are his preachers.
>> Absolutely.
>> Those are the preachers. And just like
um Jimmyi Hendrick said, man, when you
get them at this hypnotized state, you
can preach into their subconscious.
>> Yep.
>> They know it.
>> Let's look at Let's look at it. So, here
it is.
>> This is Jay-Z holding up the triangle.
>> Um uh does Satan still use music to
inspire false worship? Absolutely.
>> Everybody copy it.
>> And when he comes out, the first thing
he said, the rapper says, "Get your
hands up. You read the Bible, one of the
ways you worship is to put your hands
up, right? So they say, "Put your hands
up." Jay-Z, one of his nicknames is Hova
>> because he and in the lyrics he says, he
says, "I am Jehovah, God MC."
>> Yeah.
>> What a lot of people don't know, let me
let me break this down a little bit.
Hip-hop music. So we talked about
reggae's origins or or regga's
influenced by Rostapharianism.
Hip hop was influenced by the 5% Nation
of Islam. M
>> so the Nation of Islam is where Lewis
Farrakhan sits. Malcolm X was a part of
it. It was a black nationalist
organization that was you know had had
to me terrible views towards white
people. Now in the 60s and 70s
segregation still existed made that
thinking maybe even more uh easy to
digest. But as time went on the civil
rights movement happened things loosened
up. The other group that came out of it
was a breakaway from the Nation of
Islam. Um, Clarence 13X Powers is the
one who did it.
>> Um, and even the 13 and the X mean
something.
>> But he started a group called a 5%
nation. And only 5% of black people
would really understand this.
>> And it is that the black man is God and
the white man is the devil.
>> Interesting.
>> That is what they teach. Now, here's why
that's relevant. Because when you listen
to hip-hop music, everyone from Jay-Z to
the Wuang Clan, the Poor Righteous
Teachers, Old School Big Daddy Kane, I
could go on and on, all of them are
either members of it or sympathize with
Eric B and Rock Kim at the foundation of
hip-hop. So Jay-Z, too.
>> Jay-Z is a 5enter,
>> which is basically like a racist
organization, like reverse racist. I'm
going to say again what it it's like
rever Say what it believes, and if
anybody gets upset, they can go and look
it up for themselves. They believe the
black man is God and the white man is
the devil. Interesting.
>> That is literally what they teach. Now,
why is that relevant? Because hip-hop
became popular not because black people
bought hip-hop music.
>> Yeah.
>> I want you everyone to understand that
hip-hop became big and popular because
white suburbanite kids, that's right,
>> bought
>> hip-hop music albums. Black people in
the hood weren't buying out. They
listened to it, but they weren't the
ones spending their money on it like the
suburbanite kids were. Yeah. So here you
have a music form that comes out of a
demonic teaching. Wow.
>> And let me be clear that is a demonic
teaching, right?
>> No, we the Bible says we wrestle not
against flesh and blood, right? If if
there is a if the only devil you're
fighting is the actual devil and none of
us are gods either way. Both sides of it
is is bad.
>> The tree of knowledge of good and evil
at that point. Yeah.
>> So this is the basis of all of of much
of hip-hop music. I'll say it that way.
So, what does that mean? Well, you jump
to like Kanye West. Here's Kanye West
wearing a Baffomet t-shirt.
>> Now, some of you know who Baffomet is.
He's a demon. Um, he is goes back to
Alistister Crowley who promoted him very
well. For those who don't know who Alice
Crowley is, he was a British occultist
who the Beatles and I don't have those
slides here, but the Beatles have him on
the cover of their Sergeant Pepper
Lonely Hearts Club Band album. He
influenced I have a book about him and I
got about a third of the way through and
stopped reading it. the number of people
this man directly influence everyone
from Hugh Hefner. Uh I mean just so many
people that he influenced on a sick
twisted view of sex, sexuality,
theology. He wanted to be Satan's lead
person. So when you see someone wearing
a Baffomet t-shirt, there's pictures of
Beyonce wearing Baimett rings, all
>> the the Baffomet,
that's the very symbol the Church of
Satan uses for their actual church
>> and the temple of Satan now.
>> And she's married to Jay-Z. and she's
married to Jay-Z. Look at what Ton Kanye
West said this years ago. I sold my soul
to the devil. That's a crappy deal. At
least it came with a few toys like a
happy meal.
>> So he admits it and this is him down
here wrapping it with Common over here
on the side. And there's Kanye there. Um
and so he says, "Look, I sold my soul to
the devil." He he he you know, and he's
not the only one. DMX once said that as
well or others.
>> Then he comes out with a gospel album,
Jesus is King. All these people
including Joel Ostein, megaurch guy in
Houston, Texas, has Kanye West in his
church talking about Jesus and his
conversion. If you w I listened to it,
it made very little sense. And I was
like, I'm not sure the Holy Spirit's
leading this cuz it's not very it
[clears throat] it just wasn't very you
couldn't take much from it.
>> But now look at where Kanye is.
>> Yeah.
>> So, did Kanye West really become a
Christian? They say he still has church
service in Calabasas, California. But I
don't know that you can have play both
sides of this.
>> Uh when we when we kind of covered this
a couple of times um when he started
kind of turning back towards it was
interesting to listen to him say like I
asked God for this and that and God
didn't give it to me. So you know what?
I'm pretty much done with this. And it
was like wow. So like like God's not
giving you what you want from him and
that's the reason why you're just like
yep nope.
>> You know and and and it was like you
know
>> what if God not giving you something? Is
God giving you the best thing for you?
You know what I mean? Like God says no
sometimes. That's the best thing. Like I
remember when I was in Hollywood wanting
to ask for fame and fortune. I didn't
get it. I could easily have been like,
"Well, God, you didn't give it to me or
whatever." Like this. No, but God gave
me something infinitely better. He
didn't allow me to go down that road.
>> And you know, so he answered my prayers,
but just not in the way that I wanted
it. And now it's better off for it.
Well, if you're a Christian, ultimately
you want what God wants for you. That's
the true hallmark. You take up your
cross deny yourself. Whatever the road
is that you have for me, God, I will
walk the
>> because God always knows what's best. He
wants what's best for us.
>> If you if you're basing your assessment
whether God's watching or helping you or
not, and that's how you're going to
determine whether you're going to follow
him or not, that's going to happen to
you. And it gets messy because if my
Christianity with God is purely
transactional,
>> just what I can get from him in the here
and now, there is no spiritual growth.
And so what I found interesting after he
drops this, this is the response from
the church of Satan.
>> They say Satan is the best friend Kanye
has ever had.
>> Uh as he will keep him in business all
these years.
>> Wow.
>> They they said that after Kanye dropped
the Jesus as king.
>> Yep. after he came out as a Christian
>> the church of Satan's and remember do
you remember there's there's someone
very famous who's a high elder in the
church of Satan Marilyn Manson
>> he's been at his churches at his church
in
>> Alabama so did you pick up on that they
were dressed like the druids
>> at that service with the white robes and
stuff from the Stonehenge which is some
like a cult kind of thing because that
was on October 31st and that's when the
druids
>> and so Kanye and Justin Bieber and and
Marilyn Manson were all there. It's very
strange.
>> So, so again, remember audience that in
the Bible we are called to come out of
Babylon. Babylon represents spiritual
confusion. That's right. First and
foremost, it gets much more specific
than that. But it is spiritual
confusion. I believe this is just a way
to create spiritual confusion. This
blending of Christianity with the occult
is one of the things that's happening.
So, you know, you look at him now. Yeah.
>> This is Kanye West here. Now what
Christian walks around like this and his
wife I mean I could only use this
picture cuz half the time
>> I know
>> she barely doesn't she basically doesn't
have anything on
>> showing up and you saw the interaction
when I don't remember what awards
ceremony or whatever when she showed up
took her clothes off or whatever. It's
like he was egging her on like, "Do it,
do it, do it." You know, you see the
discomfort in you see the way that he's
like mad dogging her to like to like do
it. You better do it, you know? And it's
like
>> what what person would ever want to be?
Yeah. I mean,
>> anybody, [clears throat] but your wife
especially,
>> if you understand God, which which he
clearly said that he was, you know,
wanting to to turn his life over. I
mean, there's plenty of examples in the
Bible that talking about not being
naked, covering your nakedness and like
modesty. Yeah. Modesty and and and all
of those things to so to subject a poor
woman to that.
>> We have a video on this on our channel
as well when we talked about this, but
um I don't think he says he's a
Christian anymore. I think he's like
publicly denied God.
>> Yeah. When he denied, he said he turned
his back on God.
>> Wow.
>> Yeah. But I I I I want the audience to
realize though that so when you follow
these musicians, they will this is what
they'll do. I mean, I used to do a lot
on Kanye when he was even more popular.
And I mean this there's one where he's
sitting next to basically Satan.
>> Yeah. On the left hand side of him red
>> and there's like and the girls in the
thing have like the snake tongue, you
know,
>> just the craziest stuff. So you know you
what again what are you exposing
yourself to and where is it moving you
towards re receiving the seal of God or
away from receiving the seal of God
towards receiving the mark of the beast
>> having the spirit of God um the Bible
tells you what is it peace love joy
happiness temperance goodness meekness I
mean all of these things that the Holy
Spirit's granting you should recognize
that in the life you should see that in
the life you know I break
your Jacob [music]
and he formed you Israel.
I will make him a pillar in the temple
[music] of my God and he shall go out no
more. I will ride on him in the name of
my God.
>> [music]
>> Be strong in the Lord and in the power
shall strength. [music]
We shall mount
like heels. We shall run. [singing]
[music]
But by every word that proceeds from the
mouth of God. [music]
[music]
So, it it it's troublesome, but it goes
deeper. Here's this is Kendrick Lamar.
Now, he just did the last Super Bowl
show.
>> We did a video on that. We covered it.
>> It was very big. And I couldn't
understand what he was saying. And I
grew up listening to hip-hop.
>> I don't because he he has to rap really
fast cuz he says so much per song. So,
here it is. This is from an interlude on
one of his albums called Lucy. He says,
and this is him. Lucy is short for
Lucifer.
>> The Beatles did something like that with
Lucy and this guy with diamonds. Here it
is. My name is Lucy. Kendrick, you
introduced me. Kendrick, usually I don't
do this, but I see you and me. Kendrick,
Lucy give you no worries. Lucy got
million stories about these rappers that
I I came after one day was boring. Lucy
going to fill your pockets. Lucy going
to give you move your mama out of
Compton. And Compton is historically
somewhere you'd want to move out of
inside the gigantic mansion like I
promised.
>> Uh Lucy just wants your trust and
loyalty avoiding me. It's not so easy.
I'm at these functions accordingly.
Kendrick, Lucy, don't slack a minute.
Lucy work harder. Lucy gonna call you.
Watch this. Even when Lucy knows you
love your father.
>> Oh wow.
>> You you had you you did that presented
that show about Kendry Lamar and there
were other songs too, right, that you
wrote that were like reincarnation.
Reincarnation is one that I didn't put
here, but it's it definitely does.
>> You almost cannot take that in the
reverse. Like you have to take that as
it reads.
>> You know what I mean? Like that doesn't
work in the other side of the fence.
It's like man these guys that's what's
crazy is it they they teeter on this
line that's like no I'm serving God. But
if you actually look at the fruit of
what these guys are doing. I mean you
would not say that. You would not.
>> Listen even a who doesn't believe in God
at all wouldn't say this.
>> Yes.
>> If you really were aspiritual you
wouldn't say this. So, and again, we
bring I bring this up because a lot of
times if I say to you, listen, don't
listen to Kendrick Lamar. He's he's
highly influenced at the minimum, highly
influenced by the enemy. So, what I've
done, and when I went through that, I
talked about what I went through years
ago with the with with the with the
public scrutiny of my ministry, one of
the things that they they didn't like
was that I I didn't speak ill of these
artists. I would just
>> put up their lyrics,
>> let them speak for themselves. Yeah,
>> you as a Christian watching it or even
as a non-Christian watching it, ask
yourself, do you want someone who's
making deals with Lucy
>> being the one informing you or your
children?
>> Yeah. I had ministry colleague friends
like um publicly
say some terrible things because we
brought this up and was like, "You don't
understand this." And you know, it's
like what? But I can see with my own
tune eyes that somebody that is putting
a crown of thorns that's ordained in in
diamonds and costs, you know, who knows
how many millions of dollars of that
thing cost,
>> which Kendrick did,
>> which my savior came down and lowered
himself like to this mess of life that
we have down here. He's not wearing a
diamond studded, you know what I mean?
This is like so opposite of what what
what it to me that was blasphemous and a
smack in God's face. And he wore that on
stage. There was blood coming down his
face.
>> He says, "I'm not your savior."
>> Yeah, your savior. I am not something
like that.
>> Yeah.
>> But it's not just him. Kanye has done
that. Um I think uh and some of the
other rappers. I have a whole slide with
it. It is a recurring theme. Tupac
Shakur did that. It's a recurring theme
to put yourself in imagery like Christ,
but usually as Christ on the cross,
right?
>> Why?
>> Madonna. She did.
>> Madonna did it. Madonna. Madonna did
that in one of her videos with a black
Jesus way back then. And she did the
thing. She did she also did a thing with
the with the allwoman um Last Supper
scene.
>> It was like either Vogue or one of those
magazines, but she also hung herself on
the cross, but it it came up and she had
a crown of thorns.
>> She does it multiple times.
>> Yeah. Madonna has been doing that
ultimate blast for years. But the the
reason is and let the audience
understand
>> there's an aspect of Luciferianism,
Satanism, voodoo that celebrates the
fact
>> Yeah.
>> that Jesus died on the cross in a very
different look what we did in a very
different way than we do.
>> I saw that when I was in Haiti,
>> I was warned when you go down there,
don't listen to the drums. We're talking
about music. Pastors, French-speaking
pastors told me, "Listen, when you go
down there and you hear the drums, go
the other way. Do not follow the drums."
the first day we get there were
missionaries from the states um
Adventist missionaries the first day we
get there you hear the drum the first
night and all everybody follows them
except me I'm like no I was warned I'm
not going
>> and sure enough they took them to a
actual occult voodoo ceremony
>> that one of the docs that was with me
actually recorded
>> I preached for Wednesday night at the
church across the street from the clinic
way out in the provinces and was
powerful I mean one of the reasons Haiti
gets the heat it gets. I want I want
some folks to understand is
>> some of the most pure Christians in the
world
>> are in Haiti.
>> Oh wow.
>> You cannot in Haiti be a half-hearted
Christian.
>> The voodoo is too strong. The Christians
there are solid Christians.
>> And so after I'm done preaching this rah
bands, that's what they're called with
the drums and the women dancing
provocatively showing themselves
surrounds the church members and the
church. The church members just kind of
dissipate away. We are kind of left
behind with the elders and this rahrah
band. The music the beats are
intoxicating. The only way to I mean
they're not playing on any fancy drums
you get here in the states. I mean these
drums they made themselves but the beats
are just next level to what you talked
about about hip-hop earlier.
>> And some of my colleagues
start to follow them.
>> Oh wow.
>> Where they're going. And the Haitian
elder runs out of the church and he's
like, "No, no, don't go." And one of my
colleagues turns and says, "Why not?"
And he says, "They're going to wake the
dead."
>> Oh wow.
>> The purpose of the Rah bands, and you've
heard of zombies. The whole zombie
concept actually comes from Haiti.
>> Or at least at least much of the
folklore around zombies comes from they
have a way to actually make people seem
like they're dead and then bring them
back. Um, but the whole concept of the
rahrah band is that Satanists, voodoo,
luciferians, all of them celebrate the
fact that Christ died on the cross as if
Satan won.
>> Yeah. Wow.
>> Like he's touting that as like, look, we
were able to take God out.
>> Yes.
>> Like, if you just can back up for a
second and look at the universe, I mean,
Jesus is the only celestial being that's
ever died. Like, that's just
mind-blowing, right? No. But the Satan
and the rest of the evil angels and also
good angels and the rest of the worlds,
they've seen us humans live and die,
live and die, live and die. This this
means nothing for us to live and die,
right? Nobody has seen anybody from that
spiritual world die except for Jesus.
>> Mercy.
>> That must have just blown Satan's mind.
And yeah, he's using it as like we were
able to put God on there and snuff him
out. But I love how Jesus says, "Now, I
laid down my life. Don't even take it.
You didn't take it from me. I laid it up
again, voluntarily.
>> But so this voodoo music
>> from my understanding has influenced
jazz, rock,
>> blues,
>> blues, everything. Right.
>> Absolutely. And it I mean, and so some
people take this as a cultural thing.
And let me let me be as a as a
African-American of Jamaican descent.
>> Um you cannot place culture over Christ.
>> Amen.
>> Let me say that to everyone listening.
And
>> you know, if you get mad at me, it's I'm
perfectly fine with it because I believe
you will choose Barabus
>> today
>> like they did then if culture is more
important to you than Christ is.
>> And what Satan wants is for culture to
be the most important thing. He wants
you black radical like I used to be. He
wants you to see everything through the
lens of race first and my culture first.
Satan understands that every culture on
earth has been inherently corrupted by
sin.
>> So if you hold on to culture in many
ways by default you will hold on to sin
and sinful practices and rituals. So it
is inherently important that you make up
your mind when you accept Jesus Christ
that there is no earthly culture more
important than my relationship with
Jesus Christ.
>> Amen. And if you don't get that, you're
in trouble upfront as a Christian
because all Satan has to do is, and you
see it in America all the time, he stirs
the racial pot and people will
literally, you know, almost curse
Christ. Christians really get mad
because culture has eclipsed Christ.
>> Yep. I believe it too. I mean, you see
it in politics, right? The devil doesn't
care if you're on the super far right or
the super far left.
>> As long as you are not like, you know,
on that path with Jesus like like that
fight is across any genre, any music,
any I mean just all over the board. And
I believe what you're saying is 100%
true. 100%.
>> And while we're on this topic, let me
say this. It goes back to Matthew
chapter 24 and verse 7. In Matthew 24:7,
the Bible says Jesus speaking himself.
He says, "And nation shall rise against
nation and kingdom against kingdom." The
word for nation there is the word ethnos
in the Greek.
>> Ethnicity.
>> It means is where the word where we get
the word in English ethnicity.
>> He predicts that as we come close to the
time of the end there will be more
division based on human differences.
>> Ethnicity being the way that it's
described. It is not surprising that
these things get heated up. And if you
are white and you see something terrible
happen like recently happened. There's a
black guy stabbed a Ukrainian refugee
and some people order out some horribly
racist things and at the same time call
themselves Christians. You can't be a
Christian and be a racist at the same
time. Doesn't work.
>> You love
>> it's not what you can do with your
hands. It's your intentions that God
judges you by.
>> So all of us racism is a sin. Everyone
can be involved in any sin.
>> So we have got to be like listen we're
going to love God. Why? Jesus actually
says it this way. He says, "By this men
will know that you are my disciples."
How will they know that we are all God
Christ disciples? We have love one for
another. That's right.
>> And it doesn't matter what we look like.
I don't care what you look like. I care
what you believe like. I believe I care
who is your Christ. Because in Matthew
24:8, let me just finish that whole
thing. He says, "All these are the
beginning of sorrows." And if you think
the final thing, then you need to read
Matthew 24:9 and 23 and 24 of that same
chapter where he describes this time of
trouble that's coming. It will not be
because you're black or white or
European or Spanish speaking or Asian or
whatever. It will be because of one
reason the whole world is going to
galvanize against you. Because you are a
member of the remnant.
>> Yep. It is a easy thing to get everybody
to have a common enemy.
>> Yep. It is very difficult to get
everybody on the same page except for if
you have a common enemy and so you're a
child of God and you know go read the
story of the good Samaritan, right? You
got a bunch of people that p walk walked
by didn't didn't stop because there's a
man lying on the ground that's hurting
and broken and someone beat him up like
you just walked by because you like saw
what race he was like.
>> You know what I mean? Like no, we need
to be we're children of God and we see
everybody as a potential candidate for
heaven. Absolutely. That's how we need
to act.
>> Jesus said that this gospel must be
preached to everyone everywhere.
>> Kindred tongue
>> every and then shall the end come.
That's right.
>> So everyone is that valuable
>> that everyone has to hear the gospel.
And you're not going to preach you're
not going to truly preach the gospel to
someone you don't love.
>> That's true.
>> You can never be effective or authentic
in it if you don't love that person. So
that's what really does that which let's
bring us back to music.
>> This is the danger that's happening
though. The people who have taken on the
gauntlet of equality and justice and
love are actually the people who are
often anti-Christian.
>> And so I'll give you an example of of
how anti-Christian things are getting.
This is Taylor Swift. She's probably the
most popular per maybe the most popular
person in the world.
>> She is the most popular and the most the
wealthiest musician in the world.
>> Yeah. Cuz she I I did I talk I spoke in
Canada and I I was showing that 10
million people went and saw her a tour.
Wow. It made3.1 billion Canadian dollars
or something like I mean just staggering
numbers. This is Taylor Swift drops more
remixes of Willow after Dancing Witch.
So people say no she's a Christian. I've
heard her say she's a Christian but she
has this a fascination with witches. Why
if you're a Christian would you have
this? Here's a quote from her from one
of her I guess that's a tweet or an
Instagram. I don't know social media you
guys can maybe tell.
>> It's Instagram.
>> Instagram. Ever find yourself waiting
for the signal and meeting someone after
dark and happening upon a majestic coven
in the woods? A majestic coven of what?
>> Yeah,
>> witches. I have not stumbled upon one.
She says, "Me neither,
>> but do you want your something to make
you feel that like that?" Then the
willow moonlight witch version is for
you. She said on Instagram about the
moonlight witch.
>> Oh wow.
>> We have a whole video on her as well.
It's one of our most watched videos on
our channel and we actually talked about
the witchcraft that she does and there
was actually a clip because um the the
song that she's talking about Willow
>> Yeah. She performed it at her ais tour
and they have a full-on like witchcraft
kind of performance and then this guy
shot a Tik Tok video and he shouted
summon the demons and it but he was a
not a Christian at all, you know, he was
like a a worldly person. So why would he
see that and have that kind of reaction
unless this is actually what's being
portrayed?
>> Well, this this this is I think this is
a scene from the willow. He actually had
covered up covered her up there a little
bit. surprised I covered up some other
stuff. But here it is. They're burn,
this is her lyric. They're burning all
the witches even if you aren't one. They
got their pitchforks and proof, their
receipts and reasons. They're burning
all the witches even if you aren't one.
And look at what she says. So light me
up. Light me up. Wow.
>> Light me up.
>> So at the British Music Awards, we
showed this in the Taylor Swift episode
as well, she sings that song with Light
Me Up. And in her performance there,
they basically pick her up like she's
like laying on people's hands and they
pick her up and put her in front of this
giant snake that comes up with thunder
and lightning coming down.
>> So, and she's like, "Light me up." Like,
who are you being sacrificed to?
[laughter]
>> I don't want to be sacrificed to a
snake. And in the Bible, a snake
represents Satan. Now, I know that there
was this whole issue, social issue with
her when she was called a snake. and she
started embracing that kind of imagery.
We talked about all that in that episode
about Taylor Swift and explained it more
in depth. But yeah, it's it's scary.
>> Well, and I want to I want to connect
this back to our initial part of this
conversation.
>> Your it bypasses your frontal lobe.
>> It you know, it bypasses your frontal
lobe. It actually takes you away. It it
takes away your ability to listen to
this and reason and say, "Maybe this
isn't something I should be listening
to." Mhm.
>> So, I want to connect the dots. It's not
just that she's saying it. By putting it
to music, your ability to protect
yourself against what she's saying, if
you want to be protected is actually
hindered.
>> And because like most of us when we were
teenagers, you listen to something over
and over and over and over and over
again. That repetition also make drives
this deep in your head. What are the
fastest growing religions among young
people? Wikah and witchcraft. It's not a
it's it makes sense. Y
>> because this is literally what you're
being fed whether you're watching Harry
Potter movies or charmed TV shows or
witch talk on on um Tik Tok or you're
listening to this music the church does
not have access to you the same way all
of these resources do and hence
[clears throat] you start to go down
that path yourself because Satan has
that much access to you. one of my
friends, I won't I won't say any names.
He wanted to be a comedian and he wanted
you so he was actually pretty funny down
in Florida and um so he he was like,
"Well, how could I become more a big
famous comedian?" So he goes to one of
the voodoo ladies in Miami and he says,
"Listen, I want to be a famous
comedian." And the lady's like, "Yeah,
okay. It's possible." She said, "But
that's above my power level. Uh you got
to go to the lady in Harlem. You got to
go to New York." And
>> so he and his mother get in a car and
drive all the way from South Florida all
the way up to New York. He told me the
story himself and he says he gets there
and he meets this lady and she's like of
course yeah we can we can make you super
famous.
>> She said the only thing is besides the
money she said the only thing is someone
in your family has to die.
>> Wow.
>> I believe it.
>> And if that and of course he said no him
and his mother got back in the car and
went back to Miami and got forgot about
it.
>> I absolutely believe it. I mean, I have
seen enough videos of some really random
people that have connected how many
A-list celebrities, whether musicians or
actors, and they've had a intimate
family member die.
>> It's a lot. And if you just look at the
statistics of that actually happening,
>> that that that's not possible. That's
not random. You know what I mean? It's
random. So,
>> yeah, I I I don't doubt that that kind
of stuff goes on. I think one of and I I
mentioned about um I think in in our
other session about my my cousin who
took her own life. I think one of the
scariest parts of this now is that the
music is literally actually even pushing
that. Now this is Billy Isish. I had no
idea who she was. One of my pastor
friends called me and said my daughter
started listening to this someone named
Billy Isish and she is no longer the
same person.
>> Wow.
>> Um and so I started doing research on
her. I just put a couple of verses from
her up here but this is she had a she
made a music video. Good. All the good
girls go to hell. It this she looks like
this in the video.
>> She She falls from the sky. And we did a
live reaction to that. And we've also
talked about her in some other
>> episodes. And here's what she says. All
the good girls go to hell cuz even God
herself has enemies. And once the water
starts to rise and heaven's out of
sight, she'll want the devil on her
team. My Lucifer is lonely.
>> And then she has a song, Bury a Friend,
where she says, "The debt I owe, I got
to sell my soul." Here's another one
saying they got to sell their soul cuz I
can't say no. No, I can't say no. Then
here's the chorus, I think. Step on
glass, staple your tongue. Ah, bury a
friend, try to wake up, cannibal class,
killing the sun, bury a friend, and then
she says, I want to end me.
>> No, it's just like I I don't understand
why society like is okay with this. You
know what I mean?
>> This is this is bad.
>> Like like just glorifying and and
encouraging
people and and I know a lot of young
girls have this has been brought up in
just public spaces as well of just like
you know is this encouraging people to
be suicidal and and based on like what
we talked about in the other one social
media driving depression and loneliness
and then it's like all of a sudden
you're stumbling across this and
listening to these popular artists
you're depressed because of all the
technology and all these things like
this and they're they're get telling you
to off yourself that's wrong
>> so what's interesting is when you look
at these two videos you just mentioned,
they're actually connected. So, in
Barry, a friend, you see that she gets
syringes put in her back and these angel
wings start growing. And then in the
beginning of all the good girls go to
hell, you see that those exact same
angel wings come to fruition. They
become the full wings and she actually
falls down to the sky. Now, in bury a
friend, she talks about selling selling
her soul, right? And then in all the
good girls go to hell, she actually
becomes Lucifer that falls down from
heaven. So the one video starts it
selling her soul. The other video
finishes it and the lyrics say, "And now
Lucifer is lonely and she falls from the
sky."
>> Yes.
>> Wow.
>> This is heavy stuff. Again, there is a
dopamine release. And I I'll go back to
the other session we did. Remember that
everything is leading kids to be more
depressed, more anxious. It is through
music that many of them say they find
connectivity. This is where they find
their safe space. And and I I hope
families understand and I hope some
young people who watch this will just
stop. It's not that you know I used to
listen to music. I I kind of gave my
spiel at the beginning. I was deep into
music and it was moving me so far away
from God. God had to stop me from
listening to it. I remember when I was
so deep into some of this music and I
used to like not just like hip-hop and
reggae. Prince was one of my favorite
artists. Prince in hindsight really does
have a whole lot of weird oultish stuff
in his in his music. Maybe not as
blatant as some of the stuff today. Um
and there were others that we listen to.
I like Nirvana,
>> you know? I mean I don't know why I got
into I just heard one song and I was
like that is dope. And I was like I like
his music. It affected me.
>> Yeah.
>> I would I would I remember I would be
asleep in my bed as I was really heavy
into his music. I would feel like a
weight on me like I was being pinned
down. Couldn't move. couldn't breathe.
And for years, this happened to me. It
would regularly happen to me when I
sleep cuz I would go to sleep with the
music playing and stuff. It wasn't until
I got to Oakwood University, one of our
Adventist schools. And I and somebody
preach and I said, you know, let me stop
listening to this stuff. That's when it
stopped.
>> And I would go back to, you know, for a
while I I would, you know, alternate
listening to it, not listening to it.
And I found after a while there's
something about this music that
spiritually affects me.
>> You know, I have this and I stopped
doing that and I'm and I'm fine. And I
say that to young people to say some of
the discomfort in your life that you
think you're treating with this music
may actually only be making it worse.
>> Yeah. It's like the Tik Tok thing, you
know, it's like you start looking at
depressive videos and what happens? They
just serve you 93% depressing videos.
And so like that is going to keep your
mind there. If you are feeling like
saddened and depressed and now you're
starting to listen to music that's
giving [clears throat] you suggestions
and ideas, like what do you think that's
going to do to you?
>> Do a Daniel challenge. I love saying
that to people like try God. He says
come and taste and test to see that the
Lord is good, right? Come and just give
him an opportunity and say, "Okay, God,
for a month I'm gonna I'm gonna listen
to what you want me to listen to and and
watch just how much he changes your
attitude, your your you know, clarity of
mind, all that. I mean, God's ways are
true and just. And if you try it, you
give them a try, I guarantee you, you
will see the difference." So, I want to
encourage young people out there
listening to really ask yourself if you
are serious about being a Christian,
which is what I had to ask myself. I I I
don't want to put this off on them
because I had to ask it and I still have
to ask it because once once you've
listened to music, it doesn't go away.
Right.
>> I can forget TV shows like I I don't,
you know, I don't remember every TV show
I ever did, but I can drive by something
and it remind me of something and a song
will pop into my head that I have not
heard in 25 years and bam, it's in my
head again and I'm singing it and I'm
like, where did that come from?
>> Yeah. Where's the delete button?
>> That's the power of music. And I a lot
of times now as a Christian, grown man,
I say, what was I doing? If if I wish I
had known I was putting things in my
head that I would not be able to easily
remove things that in influenced you
towards making poor sexual behaviors uh
decisions I should say uh drugs and
alcohol poor decisions. One of the
things we don't get to talk about here
but let me just say it is music has been
used as the primary promoter of
marijuana and alcohol.
>> Nothing has been more effective. Look at
Snoop. I mean he's filthy rich. Snoop
has a whole song. I should I could have
put him in there too because a murder
was the case and in the video he
literally you guys probably did a show
on this one too. He does a whole thing
where he's when he was shot the devil
comes to his hospital room in the video.
>> Wow.
>> As a raven comes into the house and
offers him um to get back on his feet
and promises him everything. Basically
Snoop on camera. You can go if you want
to watch the video. It's there. Murder
was the case. He he sells his soul to
Satan. Snoop is so big, so popular. You
say how? like you what is it about Snoop
that makes it this happen? This is what
it is, right? This is where it comes
from. This music is that powerful and we
have to continue daily to say I am only
going to put into my mind that which
pleases God which which transitions us
to I think the idea of what is worship
music then. So before we go there, let
me say this.
>> If you're looking to change what you
listen to, here's my advice because
people always ask me when I preach these
things. Number one, you don't have to
listen to music all the time.
>> Right
>> in your my car now, I have worship. I
call it my de facto worship time. I will
listen to the Bible on audio
>> through my and I just listen to whole
books of the Bible. Just passively just
listen
>> just driving around. You cover big swats
of
>> just listening. I mean, it's not a Bible
study. It's just listening to the flow
of the Bible. And you're amazed when you
listen to it like a novel cuz I listen
to a lot of audible books to learn. Mh.
>> It's amazing what you pick up. And when
you do listen to music, I I would
encourage you based on what we're about
to talk about, think about listening to
hymns and scripture songs.
>> Now, I am looking for where do you find
really good scripture songs. So, if
anybody has a a recommendation, let me
know because I grew up singing. Our
church used to teach us some scripture
songs that are still in my head that I
still use when I'm in trouble.
>> Um, and I and I so I I really highly
recommend that as well. So before we
even go to this next phase, there there
are things you can actually use this
technology, your car radio, your
CarPlay, your Bluetooth, your Spotify,
your audible, whatever, and listen to
things that will encourage and uplift
you rather than move you in the opposite
direction. So I'll say that, but then I
wanted to do this. So we were in another
country, I won't say which one, and we
went to a youth worship service, and
they played this song.
>> It's called King of My Heart by Bethl.
I'd never heard the song. And these are
the lyrics to the song. Let the king of
my heart be the mountain where I run,
the fountain I drink from. Oh, he is my
song. Let the king of my heart be the
shadow where I hide, the ransom for my
life. Oh, he is my song. Cuz you are
good. And he says, "You are good. You
are good. You are good." Many, many
times there, right? And then it says,
"Let the king of my heart be the wind
inside my sails, the anchor in the
waves. Oh, he is my song. Let the king
of my heart be the fire inside my veins,
the echo of my days. Oh. Oh, he is my
song. And I was sitting there as the
kids were dancing around because the
music was very upbeat, very modern. And
I was like, "What is that really
saying?"
>> I So I, you know, I went I went back, we
we had them tell us the the songs. This
was just one of them. All of them were
like this. And we went back, my wife and
I, and we actually pulled up the lyrics
and started reading them and saying,
>> "This the lyrics don't really say
anything.
>> Here's a here's some rules.
>> Be the king of your heart.
>> Here's some rules. If you can replace
Satan in the song
>> or if the song could just easily be sung
to Satan, it's a song I don't want to
use in worship,
>> right?
>> I want the song to distinctively let me
know it is referring to Jehovah, Adonai,
Jesus, or the Holy Spirit.
>> That's a good point because in saying
something like, you know, you came down
from heaven to to to win me, you know,
that's only attributed to Jesus. You
know, it's like if you can if you you
can't you can't swap that out because
somebody didn't come from heaven to try
to save us. Somebody came to destroy us.
Exactly. You know what I mean? So, yeah,
that's a good that's a really good
>> that's one of the things I do. The
second thing is remember if you go back
to the Vatican Council and I was just
talking to someone about this. I I need
to find the actual reference. Vatican
Council 2 in the 1960s. One of the
things that they said is that they were
going to change the the liturgy of the
Catholic Church because they were losing
so many to the Protestant churches in
places like South America and Africa and
Southeast Asia and elsewhere.
>> Right? So, they said they're going to
change it. And one of the things to
change in order to stop the spread of
Protestantism
>> was the music.
>> I've heard of that. If you could get the
Protestant churches
>> to begin to sing songs that were devoid
of doctrine,
>> you could begin to move people away from
the protest.
>> Oh wow.
>> And I think this is the reason why a lot
of Protestants are now converted toward
Catholicism. And I I've heard
testimonies and stories like this
before. Literally, there was a guy on
Rouslon's channel. We did a video about
him, too. uh he was Protestant or
interested in Protestantism and then
he's like but yeah the music is so empty
the sermons were so empty and they went
to Catholicism and there's like this
beauty about it in in his words you know
there's like the palm and there's like
the the the other doctrines that he felt
more drawn to and that is sad because
the Protestant church is supposed to be
about the word of God more than anything
else it's supposed to be about doctrine
solos scriptor having this absolute
desire, this passion for God's beautiful
word to the point where you it's the
only thing you want to speak about. You
know, like what the heart is full of,
the mouth speaks, and you're like, I
want to talk about Jesus, and I want to
talk about the scriptures, and I want to
talk about what I learned because I've
been in the word. And I I agree with
you. It's becoming more empty nowadays.
>> And the thing is, the devil is happy if
your connection to Christ is purely
emotional. Mhm.
>> Because that's not going to that that if
you go back to the parable of the sewer,
that that's just not going to give you
deep roots. Because when you feel good,
you go to church and they're singing
these praise songs, Hill Song and Bethl
and Maverick and Elevate, and you're
raising your hands and you know, we're
talking about false revival. Everyone's
crying and it's so emotional. I feel I
feel so close to God. Y
>> So when you don't feel like that,
>> yep. Y
>> now the assumption is I'm not close to
God. Your closeness to God is found in
principle and obedience.
>> That is best illustrated as well in our
marriages, right?
>> Yep.
>> If your marriage is based on how she
makes me feel,
>> what happens when she doesn't, you know
what I mean? And it's like it should be
a built on a principle and you are going
to love that person in sickness and in
death and in health and in everything
else, right? And that principle is what
your relationship is built on. And it
can roll through the rocky times and
roll through the other ones. If you're
grounded on that, but if you're just
always looking at God going, you know,
um, I need to feel you, God. I need to
feel you, God, the second that that you
don't feel that. I mean, there's moments
that that, you know, Jesus, why did he
cry out on the on the cross saying, "My
God, why have you forsaken me?" Right?
>> It wasn't a feeling that he was there
experiencing. It was built on Lord, I
know you're there and I'm gonna do what
you're asking. Even
>> like the three Hebrew boys,
>> it's the same principle. And so to
finish it up, my mother's favorite hymn,
uh, and I pray I see her on resurrection
day. My mother passed away years ago. I
give that testimony sometimes, but this
was her favorite hymn. And I want you to
see the difference between these words
and the words I just read. What a friend
we have in Jesus. All our sins and
griefs to bear. What a privilege to
carry everything to God in prayer. Oh,
what peace we often forfeit. Oh, what
needless pain we bear all because we do
not carry everything to God in prayer.
Have we trials and temptations? Is there
trouble anywhere? We should never be
discouraged. Take it to the Lord in
prayer. Can we find a friend so faithful
who will all our sorrows share? Jesus
knows our every weakness. Take it to the
Lord in prayer. Amen. The admonition
there is doctrinal. It's it's it's
designed that even when you don't feel
right, when things aren't going, my
mother was dying of cancer as we were
singing this her last waking hours. This
is what we sang because this is what
would hold her.
>> She died knowing she had a friend in
Jesus. Amen.
>> And I want people to understand music
has to be leading you towards Christ or
else or else it's going to lead you into
trouble. Mhm.
>> And last slide I have here is this this
verse. Colossians 3:16. Let the word of
Christ dwell in you richly in all
wisdom, teaching and ad admonishing one
another in psalms, scripture songs, and
hymns and spiritual songs, singing with
grace in your hearts to the Lord.
>> Amen.
>> Yeah. You can you can you can hear it's
directed towards an individual, Jesus,
Christ. You know, you hear the language.
It's clear when you read it, you know
exactly who they're talking about. That
cannot be applied to anyone else.
>> No.
>> And I just want him. I mean, we if we
went through all of them, scriptural
songs may even be better as some argue.
It doesn't matter. My point is we have
to really reassess. That's right.
>> The number two reason in one of the
studies I I quote when I talk about
young people, and I'll uh I'll do it at
church tomorrow. I'm doing one of the
talks like this. The number two reason
young people say they leave the church,
when they talked to 20 and 30 something
year olds who left the church between
like 18 and 24 or some number like that,
the number two reason they say is that
when I was in church, the experience
wasn't deep enough.
>> They said there wasn't enough real Bible
study.
>> I didn't know who God is.
>> We have learned to we we think that we
can entertain children into the church
because you can entertain people into
Disney World and Disneyland. You can
entertain people into movie theaters and
nightclubs. You can't entertain people
into a relationship with Jesus Christ.
That must be built on something far more
substantial. And so I challenge families
to say, "Listen, talk about this with
your kids. Talk about the danger uh
spiritual danger of listening to this
secular music, but also in your home.
Your kids need to be learning hymns.
When the time of trouble comes, those
songs that they sing in many of the
churches, they're not going to hold
water when you need to be holding on
with everything you have. It is going to
be so difficult. The Bible actually
says, Jesus actually says, uh, for this
elect's sake, time itself will be cut
short.
>> Yeah. Daniel says there will not be a
time such as this.
>> Daniel 12:1, nothing like that.
>> Are we preparing for that? And music can
help prepare us.
>> That's right.
>> Or it can't.
>> Depends on what we choose. So, I really
want to encourage folk in your family
worship, be intentional. We talked about
importance of family worship. Be
intentional with what you sing in family
worship. You shouldn't just study in
family worship. You should sing praises.
When I went through that thing I went
through and I was at my lowest, people
ask me, "How did you make it through?"
>> Let me tell you something. I was alone.
You
>> I was on my face crying to God. It was
so terrible, so difficult.
>> I tell people it was the three Ps that
got me through. Number one, prayer. Mhm.
>> I learned to agonize with God in a way I
never thought I could and I had others
agonizing for me.
>> Prayer.
>> The second one,
>> the promises. I learned that the Bible
promises are powerful. When you say,
"Lord, you say in Psalm 34:19, many are
the afflictions of the righteous, but
the Lord delivers them out of them all."
Lord, you said it. I [music] claim that
promise. Y
>> But the third one
>> is praise. Mhm.
>> I learned I would open the himnel and by
myself in the darkness of the situation
I was going through, I would sing and
praise God. And I learned that if you
can praise him in the storm, if you can
praise him when it's at its worst, the
Bible says that God inhabits the praises
of Israel. [music] When you learn to
praise God at your darkest hour in true
praise, really thanking him despite the
fact your whole world has been turned
upside down and you praise him, he will
be right [music] there with you in the
fire.
>> Amen.
>> [music]